hey everyone Tom here welcome back to
watching the Watchmen thank you so much
for joining us this is a you know
irregular little podcast that myself and
my co-hosts do
his name's actually on the front cover I
just realized that deaf how's it going
Def Con it's the final countdown hope we
don't get sued for using that sample Tom
and but we're here now it's weird this
issue it's sort of a filler one when I
started reading it I couldn't actually
remember the majority of it it's sort of
the issue that if you had to cut
anything you would cut this yeah so feel
free to skip this episode listener I
think there is something going on with
this issue though I didn't necessarily
realize early on and I would have agreed
of you that yeah I think it's kind of
you know it's just saying up obviously
it's still an exhibition of the genius
of alan moore and you know and dave give
is Dave Gibbons and John Higgins and you
know just just just seeing that work and
all the pieces are subtly coming
together but the issue is called two
riders were approaching and we'll sort
of go through it as we go through but I
don't if you know it's as loads of duo's
loads of pairs of people and their
relationships in this issue that like
like the you know the spilling
beforehand in the other issue and you
know the symmetry for the whole thing it
just it's a marvel to see it constructed
yeah it's really good and you write that
motif does continue from the beginning
and throughout so yeah it's a nice
little touch again I'm not a massive fat
under the issue Tom you can probably
tell but we'll get into it and maybe
you'll change my mind maybe maybe and
you know we open as we always do with
the you know should we do like a little
it's two riders when there's two riders
I think people can just imagine that
people maybe much well I'm gonna do it
anyway what are your thoughts on the the
front cover which again is mimicking
that the smiley so well
amid the radar yeah it's very ominous
and dank on you always sort of here DEP
DEFCON when it's like really serious so
it lets us know from the off that you
know shits about to go off these these
statuses of like DEFCON they never
really mean anything like the the number
on the end
I remember the the terror threat in the
UK got moved to red which means like
threat imminent it [ __ ] will happened it
just puts people in a panic when it's
not really necessary hmm
terrorist attacks happen when the threat
is like like green or something you know
I mean up in my I think it was better
when they just had the Doomsday Clock
like 5:00 to midnight or something so
it's a bit strange that more changed it
to DEFCON for this issue but you know I
can see what he's doing it's just making
you know it's serious yeah so pay
attention yeah or skip this issue
completely I did scour the image for
more clues but there's not much actually
a knob turned to two rather than one at
the top left you know everything's on
the cusp as you say it's 11:59 and it's
just yeah it's a nice edifice to see
created by these guys and we get into
actually just before we get into the
issue I should say please subscribe to
the show please comment please email us
watching The Watchmen part at gmail.com
let us know what you think of our
thoughts on the issues or your general
approach you know got some great emails
in episodes combo not many lately
actually I should say so please do
please do email in but but yeah this is
to Reuters we're approaching and we get
our first duo death with Air Force One
and Air Force two entering two riders
that was that good government if that
was even the jingle I come up with but
yeah two riders so it's the President
and the Vice President being taken to an
underground bunker and obviously you've
said the little smiley face on the radar
screen it's actually quite comedic
seeing President Nixon just sitting in
the back of like Air Force One or a
helicopter looking really Stern
and you know the world's on the brink of
war and it but it's quite comedic to me
I don't know if it's a way that Gibbons
has drawn it but yeah it's quite funny
yeah yeah it is yeah it's sort of a
caricature to a certain extent but it's
still quite faithful it Gibbons is so
good at doing that sort of stuff and
yeah anyone that knows James gillray the
sort of Victorian cartoonist it reminds
me a little bit of it something that um
I wasn't aware of def that was an
something that passed me by when I was
reading it really and only I got this
from looking at other analyses of
Watchmen so the the six panel of page
two shows the vice-president tripping on
the stair I didn't actually know all
right yeah I thought he was just rushing
down yeah yeah yeah I mean this analysis
is ready as tripping and I think it
probably is yeah because it's basically
talking about you know this
vice-president for who's forward in here
President Ford he was apparently known
as an awkward president this was a Chevy
Chase skip on Saturday Night Live and he
was just you know a bit of a klutz
in general so yeah again they're just
nice allusion to the world it's aping
yeah it's really good
nice little setting for it as well it's
it's not very common that in the
watchman universe we get put into this
chill scenario I think this might be one
of the only times yeah so it's nice that
we we finally get like a government
perspective on everything instead of
just like the the street-level hoods or
dr. Manhattan and I don't again I don't
know this is purposeful or not but I
definitely see the atomic football that
the president's carrying in the fifth
panel especially koyla to mimic the
rotary blades of the chopper yeah no I
think you're right there something
there's a good little spot yeah did you
see what off the internet that one not
that one no no just saw that was a shape
one so it's easier to do than like
historical [ __ ] but yeah we washed in
this rich orange light over the command
center and how'd you say these aren't
settings we see these are clean settings
they're not otherworldly like Mars or
kind of you know an ulterior nowhere or
a prison or a shack or something like
that you know it is a kind of heightened
environment and you know the the idea
that it's building is that you know we
truly are on the cusp of full at
Armageddon yeah and from there we go to
New York and we see Rorschach and Dan
it's another two riders yeah yes we've
got the Twin Towers in the background as
well yeah yep definitely I don't know
why whenever I see the Twin Towers now I
think like the writer knows that they
got destroyed that's very weird I think
they've been fictionalized so much that
they use like is such an way of like
displaying what error it is hmm it's
very much shorthand and obviously more
couldn't have known this no no unless
that's snake God's been telling them
stuff but yeah it's nice just to see the
New York skyline it is oh they're
floating in the bay as well on Archie
yeah yeah he's he has so many different
uses he can just do so many different
things which says a lot about his career
I love as well them rising in the first
three panels as well yeah as we go above
the water which is just Q there's so
much cute stuff in Watchmen that just
conveys motion so well and I love that
and again I don't know if I'm being a
bit of a nerdy art critic loser but the
Twin Towers we see and the mood and we
sort of see Archie's eye as well quite
mood like and this kind of shattered
towers in front of him I don't know if
they're supposed to echo okay so you
think more did no wife is a panel in
Aussie my daughter's is like TVs like
Nostradamus awesome but you also write
it's like our friends I think has it
where you always see any kind of it's
kind of painful it leaves a tinge yeah
and it's weird that it was never
intended to be like that like that is
now you've said it there is clearly like
two shattered towers in front of the two
twin towers and but obviously more
believes that time is cyclical and maybe
tapped into something there mm-hm would
be interesting if we ever got him on the
show to Kenny was asked about that yeah
we should try me we have spoken my game
on the show I mean we've had John
Higgins on the show so a reckon we'll
get Dave Gibbons so maybe Alan like you
know he seems like he's sort of quite
jovial and giving to lesser cause hiss
so maybe pity us don't listen to this
and you know we'll call ourselves the -
right
and he'll be like wow these guys they've
got it locked out a bit
he hasn't spoken about Watchmen publicly
for many years and why would he really
you know yeah very old by this point in
it's probably because every time someone
asks my question it's like Watchmen
related and he's like look yeah I did it
I don't know about the years ago mate
just just leave it like Harrison Ford
he's being asked the same Star Wars
questions since 1977 you know what I
mean
he doesn't care anymore yeah yeah more
it probably doesn't care either he
probably hates that too Raiders
yeah I think you despised watch friends
in town yeah you know I think he hates
what it represents but obviously we
adore it and you know it's so full of
these references that are just kind of
overwhelming when you consider how how
loaded the panel's are especially when
the two guys are discussing you know
kind of what's coming next and we see
all these posters death of all these
things that we've spoken about over
these past episodes yeah it's great and
the world is just so immersive as usual
and the panels are literally just packed
with imagery you could just study them
for ages and I love how when Rorschach
climbs into his apartment there's a
little callback to his appearance in the
first issue yeah when he was perched on
the ledge there and it's just a nice
little callback but now he's out the
costume and it it feels like there's
more at stake and whereas initially he
was investigating something now he's
like you know he's down at the Bob bare
bones of things yeah yeah yeah you're so
right about the image of him entering as
well which is of course the splash panel
to @midnight all the agents and you know
beautifully done and also the you know
it's almost it almost feels oh do Stu
point this out which is a fancy word for
pointless you know when he's describing
how hanging on by my fingernails and
never looking down as he lowers yourself
boys thing you know it's it's ironic
that OTS is the most pointless word you
could use to so pointless
is this the faster we get his landlady's
name on page six missus Shep
I've got no idea no might be maybe I
remember what happening this morning
I'm not quite sure and you know we see
Rorschach
you know bathed in this light that he
often is he looks quite masculine and
majestic and pristine and he shows mercy
here boy yeah not telling the kids what
his mommy's but almost by her saying
that it's or says what she is but you
know I like it yeah and I think it's
triggered by the the expression on the
boy yeah it's a very touching moment
obviously Rorschach we've seen his
childhood throughout the comic and you
know it doesn't say like you does want
to hurt this woman but he knows that if
he introduces this child through a
violent life that it could lead to him
one day leading a violent life mmm and
it's just it's a nice way that of
showing that Rorschach will sort of
always choose to be the hero
like it's he's very black and white and
methodical in his definition of right
and wrong so he knows this is wrong and
he knows it could cause trouble even if
it would make him feel good and even if
it is probably justice for him to do
something to this woman it's nice that
he still chooses you know the good path
yeah a we see no owl in this page as
well three times just in the darkness in
the third panel he sort of hovers in the
fifth panel you sort of seemed just a
bit of his head coming out the doorway
which I really like and then similarly
in the eighth panel as well you know
he's there the scene is carved out as
you say and yet the blood still
splattered on him of course him going
back for the journal which was plays to
the personality so well and we enter you
know some interesting terrain here you
know Ozymandias is land here Carnac and
you know I love this sequence for out I
think the color scheme especially just
denotes utter power yeah it's a great
use of purple in yellow as well which is
obviously a Zemon dieter's colors and
it's luxury and I've never sort of
really considered it that Osmund I sort
of represents the corporation's
controlling everyone and he really has
got complete power
people's lives and I love her just the
way that he says he wants all of the
monitors on and to randomize the channel
every 100 seconds like he's some sort of
omnipresent god that's able to see
everything across the world all at once
Manhattan esque yeah exactly yeah and we
also see him suit up which kind of gives
you the clue that he's stepping back
into his old persona so you sort of know
know something's coming even though that
you know as a reader if you were reading
this for the first time you've not
really been made aware of it and if you
worried for the first time you might
question like why is he suiting up
because he hasn't been made aware of
anything by Dan or Rorschach yet so so
why has he taken this warning and it's
obvious that it's because he knows
what's coming really um but yeah it's
very nice characterization of him as a
villain I love this it's not two riders
they're Tom there's about four of this
is a lot there's a lot yeah there's a
lot of monitors as well
I love how just me in the world the
caption has you know the screen sort of
react to it in a certain way that arrows
pointing down from it a man is running
into it a woman is revealing it I don't
know you know make what you will I did
to study these screens quite closely and
I also like how the film reels on the
projector stand a kind of nuclear ask
for well shelter risk yeah now that's a
really good spot as well I totally
missed that
but yeah you completely right and it's
all sort of building towards this theme
of nuclear war and analyzing the media
as human dies even mentions that there's
increased sexual imagery in candy
adverts yeah and which is apparently
common in times of war and he talks
about investing in baby foods and
maternity Goods and stuff like he's ever
the business man really um and you sort
of I mean awesome and I see he says that
he's doing things for the good of
mankind but I don't know how genuine he
is because throughout this issue and
especially in the linear notes you learn
that there's always sort of a business
mentality to everything that he does and
yeah he's just recording it as well for
further study
to archive which is nice and thus no
beating outside these these green
windows and Bubastis is silhouette a
wonderful shot of him on the chair and
you know a lot of the issue is dealing
with how did he get to this point you
know how are they gonna make sense of
this how does a conspiracy actually you
know be cognizant to any of them be
coherent and we get that through
Rorschach and Dan and a lot of sequences
of the hem not only traveling under
water but I suppose subconsciously you
know plowing deep within themselves as
they explore these landscapes and I
especially love the physical interaction
between Rorschach and down which is
similar I guess to wind down held Laurie
sound for too long yeah definitely and
they're sort of getting cabin fever in
because basically they're waiting in
archie until nightfall so they're just
stuck down about the bottom of this
river waiting for the Sun to go down and
you know they start turning on one
another but the reconcile in you're
right it is quite a touching moment that
shows that they are friends deep down
they're both fighting the same battle
they're just gone about it a different
way and it is a nice touch like me and
you Tom I send you insults all the time
by text but you know I care about you
down here right we're if we're a bit
like Rorschach and niteowl us and wow
wow yeah I see I see the illusion
actually I don't know I don't know who's
Who but and you know you know what they
are was there two riders they yeah yeah
and yeah we should start asking
questions in the underworld Rorschach
says isn't that what we're doing dan
says that they go in these subterranean
depths which is just I don't know it
gives me this hypnotic the fish going by
and the slightly Algy tanker wreck and
deliciously done NH is exciting that
we're finally seeing these guys we've
seen them in flashback we've heard them
spoke about together but we actually get
to see them I guess in the real time of
the narrative right now you know
erupting out the waters triumphantly ya
know it's great and that's one of the
defining images from the Watchmen
trailer as well and just Archie bursting
out of of the war so it has clearly you
know had impact on Pete
you've seen it and I just loved the way
the boy rocks back and forth as well
it's just great and then from there you
go on to the Black Pearl and so again it
follows the water motif and the black
sorry I don't even like that movie
either so I don't know why I mentioned
it and but he the guy he arrives on
shore mm-hmm and because of these
insanity
he thinks he can the only thing that he
can do is murder everyone
he's mistakingly assumed that his homes
been attacked and everyone is in on it
so he has to kill them all to save the
rest and this is basically the same way
that Ozymandias assumes that the world
has gone to war and he must kill
everyone to stop it and it's clear that
the right of the black freighter
obviously aligned with this camicazi
mentality so it gives reason to the fact
that he was picked to work on Osmund
Isis Island as well and it is it's
really nice tie-in
you know I've slag the black freighter
off I've even called it the black pill
sometimes young um and yeah it's it's
just it's nice it's a nice tie-in Erik
Ferguson he he said it took him 30 years
to enjoy it and it's you know if you
read it a couple of times you do start
warm to it have been mmm I think this is
particularly a good sequence actually in
a kind of okay issue I suppose compared
to the rest this is probably yeah that's
black freighter sequences you know
especially for him coming onto the
island seeing these kind of you know
this moneylender from davidstown not
understanding how how they could have
been a must have collaborated you know
just completely missing the Thurman
situation but you know Vinson Lee and
the ribald chuckling reached the water's
edge ceased became a scream eye raft
were discovered and there's just a kind
of corpse staring up at these these
fancy feet and I just delicious him
killing her as well the moneylenders
head buster a single blow exploding as
if pressured by the guilt within yeah
and then I love the way that he says the
woman I strangled this took considerably
longer than I had anticipated like he
just paint such a picture yeah the two
riders Tom if you will right I'll do the
jingle must be other probably sick of it
yeah it's yeah again it's just building
on everything in everything's perfectly
aligned and we then go from there to the
news vendor mmm he was reading about the
bite method again you can see two men on
there yep yep
I will give you bodies beyond your
wildest dreams I suppose you know if you
look at what he's done to these bodies
like and what I took from that was that
this sort of ties back to veidt's
investments and he wanted to kind of do
a bodybuilding thing because he knew
that war was coming and people would
kind of want to make themselves stronger
to fight and so he's sort of selling
this method that's gonna transform you
into a bodybuilder beyond your wildest
imagination and of course if the war
happens you're gonna think I only it'd
be stronger need if I I'm gonna use this
buy method so again it shows that as
human dies is very methodical and
analytical and that heart is always the
businessman you know where is this guy
on the beach he's just [ __ ] mental
Tom yeah that's right a lad whose
[ __ ] mental
he's mirrored with the kid I forget the
kid's name he's always reading the
comics at the thing they're both on the
floor they're both crouched they're both
you know everything jocks positive of
everything in such a wonderful diamond
structure it's quite incredible and we
get back to one of Rorschach's most
prized horns this is the club you know
it's going for information here yeah I
love this scene as well it's very brutal
its Rorschach basically interrogating
someone but I love the way that they
walk in as two riders Tom and they kind
of looking for information and everyone
just sort of turns and looks at this guy
so you bastards I buy you drinks you
sell me out what kind of town is this
[ __ ] just kind of goes over and just
crushes the glass in his hand and then
starts interrogating them and it's it's
strange that like
dan sort of an onlooker and he tries to
stop him in you know he doesn't get that
involved but then he learns of Hollis
Mason's death and it really speaks to
how emotions can drive us to do insane
inning and cruel things really and it's
sort of interesting that later vite ham
says that he made himself feel
everything I feel every death and it
speaks to sort of how emotions can
either be a positive or negative thing
and the fact that Dan goes over to this
like not head in the first place sort of
shows the prejudice and maybe that he
isn't the Boy Scout that he claims to be
he sort of just as dirty as Rorschach
but he's operating you know with a sense
of privilege hmm certainly yeah and what
he discovers unfortunately from this guy
that he's you know victimizing wearing
and not doesn't mean I'm connected with
that stuff last night a lot of people
dress like this man I guess a lot of
people dress like these guys as well you
know a lot of people were live that life
and we find out about the death of
Hollis here through Dan which is treated
quite briefly I think in a good way but
it's not kind of lingered on too much
even though it'd be quite a big thing
for him yeah this is sort of you know
you've got to just get on with it
when you're a superhero a lot of the
time you don't have time to grieve you
know I'm talking from personal
experience yet um but like Batman for
example I know that's always my go-to
and but a lot of his you know allies and
stuff have been killed throughout the
years and you just gotta get on with a
job there's bigger things at stake here
and you wanna be the hero then you've
got to be better than everyone else yeah
rush like ever the pragmatist seeing the
gang murders Mason it supports the mass
killer theory
yeah and he's right yes right I guess he
I guess he is right I mean he's wrong
because it was a chance in a sense but
he does as well and it's good how
there's sort of a good cop bad cop
routine throughout this section that
sort of alternates like Rorschach starts
playing the good cop
and dance that's been the bad one and
but yeah I still see some little 8
Adrienne anecdotes come in as well
telling me the Egyptians regarded deaf
as a voyage and you know we then skip it
into this boat tethered outside the
island we're seeing lots of the people
that we've heard about at the end of the
article I think it's of the new
frontiersman all these various
characters here and then we get to more
two riders literally I guess you know
riding walleston is a is max Shea and
here am a nice you know the latest ones
of this motif and I mean yeah they're
that they're decimated unforeseen
procreate yeah it's a shame but who the
[ __ ] were there anyway Tom you know I
mean just kill them all kill all my
characters you know that they were boat
would get bumpy but you just go at the
bomb which again is following the motif
of five to midnight and so it's again on
on the bomb it's just giving me this
little feeling that oh [ __ ] when stuff
goes five to midnight it's about a
[ __ ] go off so it's nice that was
follow this and you can see the little
vagina alien sketched out on me little
little bit of canvas there so again it's
just foreshadowing everything and the
moon descending yet another great
example of the way the momentum is
conveyed here you know you get the sense
of it not just like drifting ashore as
this as the moon slowly saying ya know
just notice the little vagina drawings
washed up on the shore there as well
yeah here so it's in the top left of the
first panel and then the bottom right
the last one it lives beyond these
people who have created it yeah and we
get them a lot of classic superiority
getting in the villains lair you know
finding their motif final net plan even
him writing you know I'm leaving for
Karnak on November 1st just yeah you
know it's something he would have
digitally or not at all or just remember
it you know he's a smart man in the
world so it's a it's a little
interesting that you would do that but
but yeah then going through here
exploring a great sequence right
yeah and they discover like this little
clues that kind of depict what's gonna
happen and like they discover a chart
that shows the rise in population and
mirroring the claim in the likelihood of
a nuclear attack a hashtag Thanos was
right so overpopulation it's the biggest
thing killing the planet right now Tom
Noah wants to talk about it but except
for our God and Savior Thanos and
interestingly Tom did you like infinity
war like I did I thought I thought it
was pretty good actually I was pretty
good yeah well I thought was excellent
one of my favorite films ever wait why
can't why can't famous just trade food
though or like redefined the concept of
resources and surely over planets that
were okay and didn't need to be balanced
right because yeah and I thought about
that originally but he's known as like
the mad Titan isn't he and he comes from
a world that he sort of said to them
look here [ __ ] overpopulation is
gonna destroy this planet and there were
like no no it won't so he has tried to
take the peaceful route but it's not
worked so now he's just like you know
he's went mad with it Tom and he just
realizes like people are gonna always
try and find a way around it so I'm just
gonna kill half the hashtag Thanos was
right and one of them's gonna be of your
favorite webhead hashtag spoilers I hope
everyone's seen it by now and I'm just
ruined the ending for them Tom I did I
think the thing that pissed me off the
most is I I know the to the ruse over I
was the directors crazy [ __ ] directors
did the rest of development as well done
if you've seen Arrested Development but
Tobias fünke a he apparently has a cameo
in like the collectors lair or some [ __ ]
on me yeah I didn't see it but yeah I've
seen it twice now and I knew about the
cameo the second time and I still
couldn't spot them I knew exactly what
scene II was in as well brazen guardians
for definite and but I don't know where
he I couldn't see him in okay infinity
war we'll have to buy the blu-ray Tom
and have a look
and literally yeah literally
and that's what pissed you off about the
movie I suppose so I suppose that's not
that bad is it
no I've come here it was fine it was
fine but you know what um me and my
girlfriend well she introduced me to
some like it hot yesterday and I had
such a ball watching that film and I
just I enjoyed it so much more than if
any war and I just I I think good
writing a good drama and well paced
comedy is just it's more interesting
okay well what the [ __ ] are you doing on
the comic but I had time but but yeah
him guess CBO zero dies his password as
always marry me no I find hilarious I
always love in films when people hack
computers like there's an absolutely
terrible one in Batman and Robin where
Batgirl hacks are for its computer with
a name on a photo beside the computer
and it's a three-letter word it's peg
Wow and then a suit I love it a lot
every movie the sentence and as soon as
they log in all of the secret plans and
stuff pop up straight away like she's
sitting there she logs in and all the
like diagrams of all the different
Batmobiles and stuff start popping up I
think there's one in any way it happens
quite a lot and might be Iron Man where
Pepper Potts hacks or with is stains
computer and as soon as she's in all the
[ __ ] secret plans start popping up
just opening up the windows yeah I love
the way that Adrian might as he's
hacking it he nearly gets the password
right and it goes password incomplete do
you wish to add writer and that's the
[ __ ] I've just realized the writer Tom
there's the right air again yeah and but
anyway it it basically tells him look
you know you got the password right it's
not very it's not good secure is it no
it's not like much in a facebook did
that that clean was [ __ ] than they
already are Tom you I'm in for Windows
XP I think you could get a password hint
I think you could do on that but yeah
yeah it's a get yet it is contrived and
him him bathed in the greenish hue of
this Macintosh the realization there
you know what's going down and then
heading out you know to meet him and
then we get our last bit of black
freighter which essentially closes the
story for the time being the two riders
him and a dead corpse of a woman which
yes you know pretty morbid pretty
fascinating him passing a pirate century
holding his breath praying that's not
gonna be contact in passing a you know
sort of a holiday
scarecrows very haunting or it's kind of
sacked eyes and I love the end of them
racing into the front of the image yeah
and it's just a nice little signifier
that misconceptions and assumptions can
lead down a dark path in the same way
that has been dieted and yeah it's just
it's just nice and we say Rorschach also
drop his journal off and a lot of people
you know comic book writers might not go
to that extent it might just be like ah
he's just dropping his journal off just
cut that scene but it's nice how like
you get to see the journey of the
postman as well yes he takes this to the
frontiersmen and yeah it's a nice little
touch it's world-building it is it is a
drop down ladder but it's always good to
see and you see so hard to climb so
difficult to climb it's one of those
things in movies that the lightt about
isn't it like oh yeah just climb this
rope ladder and then you do it in real
life me like [ __ ] hell this is
horrendous why would anyone do this but
there's things of fairgrounds that like
you sort of got to get to the end of
some [ __ ] like that some some [ __ ] and
we see the Ganga teen elephant as well
in the back as opposed to sent off and
you know that the journal arrives and we
get to love this picture of our Chi
flowing through the story yeah it's
really nice isn't it yeah sort of like a
wallpaper for your desktop
definitely yeah the clouds are always
disney-esque there's yeah real light
weight to them and it's a complete polar
opposite to New York there's just sort
of a cleanliness to it and and you can
see why Adrian would kind of have this
retreat here it's just away from
everything it's very solemn and it's you
know it's nice and peaceful so it
reminds me of like a Japanese painting
like waves
I don't know if the composition similar
to it but just the girl as I'm so yeah
yeah yeah and the the trout shaded
towards us as well and the middle sort
of giant one and seeing them like kind
of make sense that the layer would be
above this high you know she imagined
how high they are really as they're sort
of scaling this thing and yeah the next
page is what when they crash down in the
snow and I guess you see a little bit of
the flap of the ship fly off or
something you you get to see them inside
it's all there all the paper flying
around and Dan himself Jeff jostle that
the joystick and you know yeah all that
the snow is evoke brilliantly yeah it's
just a really nice change of environment
as well and the snow is beautifully
depicted and I just loved the way that
Archie looks against the snow just those
massive eyes against the white backdrop
and it's a really good artistic touch by
Gibbons and Higgins friend of the
podcast yes great friend of the podcast
and yeah you're right as well we're in
another new environment or sort of snow
artsy bar which is a common environment
basalt action-y like inception for
example as that weird snow scene - yeah
and this all comes down nowhere but yeah
dan ever-resourceful with the gadgets I
don't really know how wash dragon is
staying coat withstands this snow this
cold but yeah they haven't done suited
up you know Dan makes me at home Tom cuz
I don't know but if you know Jordi's
right but they're stupid like that they
literally go out clubbing all night and
just t-shirts and skirts and that you
know I mean we're Hardman we're not like
new southern Shandy drinkers with your
podcasts and your your fancy book
analysis is it's a sis's so it's nice
that he's like so stubborn though he's a
acknowledges I'll just wear my coat in
what happens then Tom it's a to bloody
riders yeah yeah to Raiders how there is
a to avoid a song apparently it's by Bob
Dylan who I'm not really a big fan of
but outside in a distance of one cat did
growl which it which is lovely cause
Bubastis we see more we see as they were
you know more is adept at creating
sounds like that and animals and blue
basses always fun to play with outside
in the distance
a wildcat did growl two riders are
approaching the wind began to hell yeah
I was [ __ ] blown away by that mmm it
was brilliant I don't know what again
how more discovered this stuff maybe
it's like when people say us like quote
Oscar Wilde it and they just make up any
quote and then he put his name at the
end of it but literally this Bob Dylan
quote is perfect and it sums up the
entire end of the issue and again before
Google you could say every time it was
before Google so what's nice is the the
song that it comes from all along the
watchtower which probably more more
files for the Jimi Hendrix version it
plays in the film doesn't it as they go
into the snow I believe yeah not as
subtle in the film but still nice yeah
yeah and I love the you know that the
end material as well the toys that we
see the businessman as you say the via
is and all the descriptions of the toys
are fantastic as well and the ship boob
a ball look you can get oh they look
great yeah unlike the little letter
discussing the watchman figurine line
like it's quite funny how they literally
just throw everything in yeah I remember
again Batman and Robin when that came
out I went to Argos to get some toys and
in the the Robin in the catalog was like
night camouflage Robin and so I bought
it and when the but when it came out
they were like oh we didn't have any of
that and we've only got ice fighter
Robin a stomach's to be like that and it
was literally the same figure it just
painted white on some bits well and I
the same way that they have Bubastis in
it it's just funny and because that is
literally how toys [ __ ] works
anyway I recommend everyone that check
out and toys that made us on Netflix
because that's brilliant documentary
about stuff like this mmm
and and good friend to show psychosis
Holocaust stuff right yeah exactly yeah
yeah it's quite funny how they mentioned
Moloch is dead as well but he's not
copyrighted so it's okay to make a
figure yeah I'd buy these toys like they
the same you got like the next paid to
go new figure and
it's got new accessory yeah this is
great if DC did this as a set and made
it it would sell what hotcakes
yeah it's one of them toys that you
would see on eBay listed for like 300
pound isn't it and someone would [ __ ]
pay for it as well probably the most
pertinent thing here is the nostalgia ad
where yeah there's point to the future
where they're gonna do millennium you
know he's gonna as you say he controls
all the things so he can really control
mood as well and influence from through
smell here of all things for the scent
yeah you know I love this sequence as
well and all in all more obviously
batting on 10 and I can't fall anything
here yeah they just talked about I like
they chose androgynous models to
advertise nostalgia as well so they can
appeal at the gay market as well and the
marketing of wars really beautifully
discussed here um and it's it's
fascinating to think how during like
peacetime certain products have put
forward in a certain way and it's just
great and then they go into the byte
method where it's talking about the
meditation and mind state needed to
build a perfect body and it's obviously
just preparing people for war and again
there's so much subtext here and more
does a brilliant job but I [ __ ] hated
the issue Tom yeah no it was all right
wasn't it it's all right I just don't
think it's as good as the rest no no I
think I think it kind of is essentially
setting up the end game yeah you know he
needs to kind of have these move modes
but but ya know I enjoy it and these
next two issues you know are gonna be a
treat to go through as always let us
know in the comments subscribe to the
show let's go at the Deaf Channel if you
got a million views recently is right
million total on your channel well yeah
really blown away by it and genuinely
like quite happy with how the channels
developing and I think most channels
tend to have either be really popular
all of the time but have no niche stuff
and then there's some channels that have
loads of initiative but just aren't
popular
and so it's good that you know I really
enjoy doing this and it's good that
we've got like a little core following
who enjoy it and then you know when I
want when I want me million views Tom
Lee I just go off and do something I
just pretend like every Ferguson
actually commented on the last video
saying please call your final episode
the ending of Watchmen explained so he
knows what my strategy is Tommy's
figured it out yeah yeah I've actually
just dropped a Deadpool 2 and then
explained as well though so make sure
you go watch that yeah that's cold it's
got all the post-credits scene talk Wow
it's song the spoiler review but I just
call it and explain to get more views I
said then fungal pops don't pay for
themselves Tom no no truly not really
not and you know yet subscribe to bow
rot resume as well me and death of John
tons of episodes on they're completely
different focus from this yeah exactly
you've got an itch following haven't you
Tom yeah a little bit of a following
yeah I love it yeah say I love these
little nice following exactly yeah
that's what they're there for and you
know there's quite a few other people
that I fought like I found this guy
recently has like 700 subscribers on
YouTube just reviews like old like 70s
rock albums and [ __ ] yeah right and it's
like he doesn't get many views but I
don't [ __ ] get more in sending
anything on TV like that you know it's
good there's lots of channels out there
and you know popularity doesn't define
quali I called my popular videos a
pretty [ __ ] Tom yeah and these ones are
pretty [ __ ] as well but you know
actually it's something interesting I
got given a Batman comic from 1959 as a
wedding present
and so that's crazy just getting like a
60 year old comic and I did it was funny
because the guy who gave me a bra and
like in it like a like cardboard
envelope like do not bend and I just
literally took it off him said our
thanks took it out the envelope had a
look at they put it back in quickly and
then just stored it away like then the
Raiders of the Lost Ark I'm just kidding
now obviously I looked up how much it
was worth on eBay and sold it straight
away then Funko pops do not pay for
themselves Tom oh my god yeah I want to
handle
old comic that'd be cool you don't oh
it's too much pressure
it's like when it's like being given a
newborn baby yeah and you just they
don't drop it don't touch it what do I
do and next thing you know you've ripped
it in half dollar Wow well uh yeah we
will be back soon for Doomsday Clock
whenever the [ __ ] that's coming out I
think it's been pushed forward like as a
bi-monthly other you know I don't really
read modern comics I'll just read trades
and stuff so it's kind of weird to sort
of have to live through this yeah nice
distance it's it's frustrating reading
stuff issue by issue as well because you
forget like he literally especially when
it's it's three months since the last
one you know I should never have done it
Tom but what if their views were yeah
it's slapped or in the face that's
everyone the folks we've are hating on
my any more than you think of Doomsday
Clock but as ever this has been great
man um you know what I don't know what
to say thank you sir you may go over a
good chatter watch whatever
you
you